so as journalism has evolved and I've
spent a lot of time in that early part
of the Internet age thinking about it
and doing it you know one thing we know
is that the supply now is greater than
ever vast supply we've a few things that
we need are going missing which is scary
like local news that we can have some
reason to believe but we're working on
that and there are things that tell me
that we may get this right eventually
vast vast supply but the lines are
blurred from what they used to be so
I'll give you a couple of edge cases
that we can agree on that that's
journalism now it's not that the post
always is right they screw up a lot but
they're basically doing journalism and I
think we could agree on that there might
be people in Washington on Pennsylvania
Avenue who would challenge that but I'm
gonna stick with that that that's
journalism that's not and no comment on
the on the content here just it's not
journalism whereas again that's
broadcast news in the world is the BBC I
think we certainly english-language and
clearly journalism even though they're
not perfect that they are fabulously
good and this is not I want to be really
clear I love the fact that people create
media and I love the fact that NAT and
foxy some friend of NAT and Foxy's did a
video of their bed dancing and put it up
on YouTube and that 50 people or so
watched it I think that's wonderful
absolutely wonderful it's just not
journalism that's my only point it gets
blurrier in every way when we starts
thinking about what's happened in the
last 20 years with people walking around
with tools of media creation in their
pockets this young woman named Nita was
shot and killed in the streets of Tehran
a decade ago
be a little more probably by a
government sniper and someone walking by
with a video camera that was inside of
his telephone took heartbreaking video
of her death in the street and this made
its way around the world in fact it
later won a very major journalism award
the video but it was taken by someone
who has never was never a journalist
before and hasn't been in one since it
was a random act of journalism which we
all can do and increasingly we should
think about what what we will do when
were in that position
you